I'm excited because I'm using this
episode of the observation deck to
introduce a new idiosyncratically
occasionally recurring feature which i'm
going to call Blade Runner watch you
might remember the movie Blade Runner
was supposed take place in November of
2019 that gives us about seven years to
prepare seems like a good time to start
watching out to make sure that that
stuff either is coming true or isn't
coming true anyway it's worth noting not
because I'm worried about replicants but
because well because the Empire State
Building has new lights you probably
know that the Empire State Building in
New York used to do this thing where
they would change the color of the
lights around the observation deck and
the tower depending on like a holiday be
red and green for Christmas or orange at
Halloween something like that well they
just install the new set of lights
they're using LEDs now so they're super
bright and they can get thousands or
millions of colors they can change the
colors on the fly they can do animations
the lights can go up and down the tower
on election night they actually had the
the electoral vote tally red and blue
which turn the whole building into
essentially an infographic which I sort
of love I've talked about on this show
before the power of putting words on
cityscapes but that powers magnified
exponentially when the words actually
move when the buildings can teach you
something when I was growing up in LA
there was a building the mutual of omaha
insurance building that had a rotating
beacon on the tower i think because when
it was built airplanes actually flew low
enough that if they didn't see the tower
they run into it there used to be an
airfield near there of course by the
time I was a kid that wasn't a problem
and by the time I was a teenager they
actually took that down and they put up
a light up beer sign if I remember right
so these the the Empire State Building
is isn't quite like that beacon you know
there was one on the John Hancock
building I'm remembering now actually
the shorter one in Boston and you could
always tell somebody who lived in Boston
for a long time because the color of the
light at the top of the beacon was a
weather forecast it was always snowing
but so that was another example of a
building that was conveying information
the cityscape was conveying information
if you knew how to read it the umpires
day plays a little bit different though
because it can move because it's
animated that's a little bit more like a
zipper those the lights that news
organizations will put on the outside of
their
buildings like in Times Square to give
the headlines you know the Japanese are
way ahead of us on this kind of stuff as
I guess was often the case their
downtown's in Tokyo were full of these
animated active surfaces right
multicolored lights flashing on and off
moving around and now of course here in
the US we're starting to see more and
more of these LED billboards right which
are sort of the same idea another active
surface instead of having a painted
billboard or billboard that was more
like a shrink-wrap poster that people
would post now LEDs are bright enough
and and cheap enough that you can have
the whole thing be essentially a TV
screen addressable pixels right that you
can just program and most of the time
those are static the ones on the
approach to the east bay off the bay
bridge they'll change but basically it's
one single image but you can just as
easily animate those that's where the
blade runner thing comes in you might
remember in the movie there were whole
walls of addressable pixels on buildings
mostly used for advertising and they'll
do some of that in times square now to a
lot of what used to be static billboards
in Times Square now basically big TV
screens I will say I find that very
distracting and that's not surprising
right the human eye and the human brain
the visual perception system is tuned
very highly for promotion like like any
other animal that had to deal with you
know fast-moving predators coming at us
from the sides we're very good at
picking up change in our visual field at
picking up things that are moving around
right we see that and then we fixate on
that stuff in fact the outer edges of
our visual perception probably somewhere
around here for you are basically all
motion detectors we don't actually see a
picture but if something moves will pick
it up what that means is if you've ever
seen a kid standing in front of a
television you know that moving images
are hypnotic and that really throws me
off my game in game in a city I if I'm
looking at a TV screen instead of a
building I kind of don't know where I'm
at in a town so I guess this would be be
the negative Blade Runner watch because
it really makes me a little uneasy to
see TV screens where I think a picture
or building should be I'll tell you know
who's not bothered by the stuff at all
replicants